[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurent saint martin bonjour bonjour
d'être avec nous députés la république
en marge du val de marne rapporteur
général du budget à l'assemblée
nationale en détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord aujourd'hui un bon
jour yann ce député bonjour on commence
bien sûr par la crise sanitaire laurent
saint martin emmanuel macron qui retarde
la décision d'un éventuel confinement
tout en semblant donc jeudi préparer
comme le montrent les dernières
déclarations de gabriélat talent sur un
confident couvre feu qui serait
insuffisant pour stopper l'épidémie
pourquoi tant d'atermoiements est-ce que
l'exécutif a du mal à trancher la
question
ce que vous appelez atermoiements c'est
un exercice de transparence est le
propre de cette majorité depuis la crise
et d'expliquer chiffres à l'appui
comment avance malheureusement l'avancée
de l'épidémie et parfois heureusement
son recul et nous voyons bien que cette
période en accordéon elle est difficile
en termes de décisions publiques à
prendre et elle doit être fait au plus
juste et au plus précis et donc il y
aurait deux manières de faire soit on
dit rien jusqu'à avoir suffisamment de
données permettant de prendre une
décision
et à ce moment là on entretiendrait un
flou plutôt une inquiétude qui serait
légitime soit en expliquer c'est ce qu'a
fait par exemple le porte parole du
gouvernement hier à l'issue du conseil
des ministres il expliqué les la
situation au fur et à mesure et explique
que le couvre-feu à 18h nous voulons en
savoir davantage sur son efficacité
aujourd'hui il ya des résultats
peut-être pas suffisant et donc il y
aura des décisions qui seront et ses
hommes prochainement puisque je crois
assez transparente vis-à-vis de nos
principales autour de nous on sent quand
même que ce supplice de la goutte à
goutte commence à vraiment a pesé sur
les français et y en a même autour de
moi qui prennent les pronostics
simplement pour savoir quand est-ce que
je veux confinement va démarrer lundi
mardi et ce qu'il est patent quand même
de prendre la décision et surtout d'en
finir avec cette cette inquiétude est
cette lassitude des français autour de
cette prise de décide alors la lassitude
des français par rapport à la crise et
par rapport au fait que les décisions
soient prises tard je la comprends mais
à nouveau que ne dirait on pas si
c'était silence radio pendant quinze
jours
jusqu'à une décision au jt de 20 heures
on dirait décision jupitérienne on
dirait pas de concertation là qu'est ce
que nous avons tous linverse nous avons
de la pédagogie de l'explication n'est
et puis on a des divergences a senti
quand même les bruits les berges de la
friture sur la ligne
pardon monsieur meilhon il est l'elysée
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit
c'est cesser le travail dès médiatisé
aussi ce qui permet de voir s'il ya une
grande interrogation ce bruit c'est le
bruit des oppositions et les bruits les
commentaires la parole de l'exécutif et
de la majorité elle est claire elle est
claire prenez toutes les prises de
parole de l'exécutif des membres de la
majorité les décisions qui s'enchaînent
les décisions sont claires aussi elles
sont prises à la lumière de ce que nous
connaissons au film éclaire les chiffres
augmentent on a effectivement pas
suffisamment à ce stade quelle est
exactement l'efficacité du couvre-feu du
tuteur bond en avant des premiers
éléments et nous les partageons et je
crois que c'est heureux maintenant nous
avons un temps important sur cette fin
de semaine aujourd'hui demain qui est
celui de la concertation personne je
crois nous reprocherait la concertation
avec les groupes politiques au parlement
avec les partis politiques équipes
partenaires sociaux pour savoir comment
la société ce représentant souhaite
également avancer ensemble pour les
prochaines semaines et quelle décision
doit être prise la façon la plus juste
et surtout ce point de bordés à trouver
entre l'acceptation l'acceptabilité
comme on dit d'une société par rapport à
un éventuel 3e re confinement ou pas et
puis des mesures tendent à être prise de
façon évidente par rapport à le temps
pris sur supplémentaires par par le
président de la république vous avez
raison de le souligner c'est pour
aussi traiter la question de
l'acceptabilité on sent que ça inquiète
énormément les l'exécutif en parler de
lassitude mais aussi parfois de colère
est ce qu autour de vous vous sentez
cette colère monte des français autour
d'un troisième confinement qui peut être
dévastateur pour l'économie
alors je n'utiliserai pas ces termes
apocalyptique de dévastateur parce que
nous avons au contraire réagi depuis le
début de cette crise pour amortir
systématiquement les effets de la crise
d'un point de vue économique et social
pour y revenir
nous avons démontré que nous savions le
faire nous le faisons toujours
aujourd'hui je rappelle que beaucoup
d'entreprises sont encore aujourd'hui
empêcher ou ralentis et nous dépensons
au près de 10 milliards d'euros par mois
pour soutenir cette économie aujourd'hui
et nous ferions s'il y avait encore des
mesures plus restrictives donc il n'ya
pas de l'apocalypse qui nous attend avec
un troisième recours et par les mots au
kbis nous je n'utiliserais pas cette
arme est là qu il y ait de la lassitude
et de l'inquiétude
oui mais pas trahir de secret j'en ai
aussi à titre personnel comme citoyen
nous sommes tous là de la situation
sanitaire
nous avons tous envie que cette crise
sanitaire se termine nous avons tous
envie que la campagne de vaccination
progresse avance pendant que nous
pouvons enfin freiner mais il ya aussi
une réalité qu'il serait absurde de nier
surtout irresponsable quand vous êtes
aux manettes
et bien cette réalité c'est la montée
des variants et la montée des variants
il faut la considérer et s'il faut la
considérer en prenant des mesures de
restriction de circulation du virus
nous le ferons et cette manière de faire
pardon j'insiste vraiment là si cette
manière de faire c'est tout sauf de la
décision occultes c'est tout sauf une
décision unilatérales imposées à
l'ensemble du pays c'est tout sauf de la
restriction liberté c'est de la
concertation c'est de la prise de
décisions en sachant en sachant
l'efficacité ou pas des mesures
précédentes et ce en s'adaptant à chaque
mesure nouvelle par rapport à ce que
nous avons appris par le passé et je
crois pour finir que rien n'a été
parfait dans ce que nous avons vécu
depuis le début de cette crise
des erreurs ont été commises évidemment
tous les pays ont fait des erreurs nous
avons appris au fur et à mesure chez
nous mais quel est ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que la france ont les ont
menacés apparemment il y en a quand vous
comparez par rapport aux autres pays
et je crois d'ailleurs que c'est plutôt
reconnu chez nos voisins la france n'a
pas à rougir de l'efficacité de ces
décisions de ces mesures et du soutien
vis-à-vis de ses concitoyens qui a été
apprécié vous voulez un exemple tu crois
que
les mesures difficiles à comprendre
entre les commerces entre les grandes
surfaces entre les rayonnages
il faudrait si on devait malheureusement
un jour revenir à des situations de même
ordre
mieux les anticiper et mieux les faire
comprendre pour qu'il n'y ait pas
justement cette difficulté
d'acceptabilité sur un certain nombre de
choses qui peuvent paraître un détail
pour certaines administrations mais ils
sont en fait dans l'abrogation réaction
extrêmement et en sortent bien sûr parce
que le couvre-feu vous l'avez vous
l'avez rappelé et 10 milliards d'euros
par mois
si on devait les confiner on estime à
peu près à 15 milliards la dépense
supplémentaire que cela rend en cela
engendrerait pour par l'état est ce que
la france a les moyens de tenir
financièrement cette cette crise alors
pour être précis pardon c'est de la
dépense mais aussi beaucoup de moindres
recettes tout un mélange des deux
puisque évidemment les impôts et les
cotisations rentrent moins que
l'activité diminue
oui la france a les moyens de continuer
à protéger son économie santé des
emplois en s'endettant
la réponse est oui et je vais être très
clair là dessus nous avons une situation
à la fois monétaire et de la qualité du
pays qu'est la france pour s'endetter
qui ne souffre d'aucune difficulté
nous avons encore souscrit un emprunt
record la semaine dernière 16 milliards
d'euros jusqu'à 15 ans 3 euros lorsque
les vannes peuvent être ouvertes comme
ça indéfiniment
la réponse est non mais il faut bien
comprendre que nous sommes dans une
crise systémique que la france n'est pas
seule que la france fragiliserait si
elle était seule à avoir recours à
l'endettement pendant que les autres
pays seraient déjà en train de
redémarrer c'est relatif c'est relatif
et la france est aujourd'hui un des pays
qui gère le mieux la crise à la fois sur
l'urgence est à la fois par son plan de
relance
ceux qui prêtent aujourd'hui aux états
des investisseurs sur les marchés
internationaux grâce à l'action de la
banque centrale européenne qui rachète
ses créances sur le marché secondaire
sont en confiance et demande même à
prêter un pays comme la france nous
avons beaucoup plus de demandes beaucoup
plus de demandes que ce que nous
émettons sur les marchés en terme de
titres de dette et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui largement mais largement la
possibilité de nous endetter est ce
qu'il faut le faire à robinet ouvert est
ce qu'il faut le faire sans regarder la
qualité de la dépense certains noms il
faut absolument avoir recours à
l'endettement pour sauver nos emplois
il faut absolument
avoir recours à l'endettement pour
financer la relance est à dire investir
dans l'avenir et le rebond de notre pays
mais il ne faut pas s'endetter plus que
de raison c'est à dire pour financer de
la dépense courante et le sujet
s'annonce demain il sera remboursé à un
moment laurent samantha ce que vous
dites sur le plan économique le plus dur
pour les français ça va être une fois
que la crise sanitaire est terminée
alors il faut se méfier des discours là
encore un peu un peu déluge après nous
il n'y a pas de de dettes sous forme
d'épée de damoclès qui attend nos
enfants et nos petits enfants c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche puisque une tête
se refinancent en revanche il y à une
grande vigilance à avoir pour un pays
comme la france pour continuer à
démontrer son sérieux budgétaire pour
démontrer que après cette crise là non
seulement liée à une capacité de
croissance et de rebonds mais aussi
l'incapacité de réforme il ya une
capacité de faire progresser le pays de
mieux l'équilibré aussi sur un certain
nombre de mesures de comptes publics qui
permettront à ceux qui nous prêtent
aujourd'hui de continuer à nous prêts le
ministre le ministre olivier dussopt
parlait justement de s'attaquer au
déficit structurel de revoir les
dépenses ce public
une fois la crise passée on va pas en
rajouter une à celle que l'on vit sont
déjà des messages que l'on prépare pour
la campagne de 2022 oui mais campagne ou
pas j'ai envie de vous dire ces sujets
seront posées
c'est la crise qui va décider de quand
est ce que nous devrons effectivement
commencé à rétablir nos finances
publiques c'est quoi ces réformes ce
devoir est la c1 réforme des retraites
alors sur en chômage oui est-ce qu'on
peut les donner et il y en a d'autres
des réformes pour remettre à léquilibre
un certain nombre de comptes
déséquilibrés pour rien a voire
plusieurs
ce qui compte c'est de que ce soit sur
les retraites que ça sera sur un chômage
il faut regarder quand est ce qu'elle
peuvent être faites
est ce qu'elles doivent être faites la
réponse est oui la question c'est quand
au camp pour voir comprenez bien que
c'est mais c'est ce qu'ont fait ces
réformes ne peuvent par contre c'est le
travail à l'heure actuelle toutes façons
de travailler
le loi cadre par exemple pour la réforme
des retraites qui pourrait aboutir même
avant la fin du quinquennat
mais tout est possible en soit la
question c'est quand est ce que c'est le
plus judicieux pour bien compris que ça
serait pas pendant la même
elles ont pas du tout la même
temporalité une réforme sur l'assurance
chômage alors que nous sommes dans une
crise sociale n'a pour moi pas de sens
maintenant on ne peut pas faire une
réforme qui restera un chômage
maintenant bref la réforme sur les
retraites c'est différent la réforme sur
la retraite ça ne touche pas aujourd'hui
la problématique du retour à l'emploi
est la problématique de la croissance on
est d'accord
donc on l'a commencée en forme des
retraites pour nom parce qu'il ya
d'autres difficultés
c'est le temps parlementaire de débats
et la qualité seront pas tant que ça
vous servez parce que nous sommes
bientôt en février 2021
il ya quelques mois utiles encore pour
faire du débat parlementaire il ya
encore beaucoup de l'eau à passer mais
au delà du seul temps parlementaire
il ya aussi la possibilité dans la
société d'aborder un débat serein avec
des partenaires sociaux ça nécessite
vous le savez une réforme des retraites
vous l'avez vu pendant de nombreuses
années
ça nécessite une qualité de dialogue
social et de la concertation
est-ce que nous avons le temps et au
parlement et au niveau de la
concertation sociale dans notre pays de
mener aujourd'hui une réforme des
retraites d'ici 2020 2 personnellement
je ne le pense pas après si l'exécutif
pour si l'art autrement
c'était sa décision mais moi je pense
que ce n'est mais vous savez très bien
que la crise sanitaire elle a aggravé de
manière considérable déficit du régime
des retraites est ce qu'on peut encore
attendre avant de s'attaquer à ce
déficit il faut démontrer et il faut
maintenir l'ambition à la fois
d'équilibrer le régime des retraites
mais pas que toutes nos branches toutes
nos branches de de notre système de
sécurité sociale doit être équilibrée
c'est ça la véranda est visé pour la
première fois doivent être tout
équilibré c'est ça la promesse et le
pacte que nous devons avoir avec notre
pays à l'issue de cette crise et tout
devrait être frais à l'issue de cette
crise c'est ma conviction c'est ma
conviction
en revanche est ce que nous devons le
faire là tout de suite au coeur de la
crise pour moi la réponse est non nous
n'en avons ni le temps ni les capacités
de dialogue et puis surtout la priorité
reste encore reste encore
malheureusement la santé des français
le sauvetage de nos emplois et le
financement de la relance de notre
économie
tant que nous serons dans ce triptyque
là tout débat de réformes structurelles
sera à mon sens beaucoup trop tôt et à
mon sens beaucoup trop long mais
l'économie vous
li est qui et qui est fragilisée
évidemment par le couvre-feu évidemment
si la cia confinement ce sera encore
pire mais vous avez est-ce qu'on peut
d'ores et déjà enterré l'objectif de
croissance à 6% du pib fin 2021
vous savez la crise nous a appris à voir
beaucoup d'humidité beaucoup de modestie
sur les prévisions macroéconomiques donc
je ne dis rien avec certitude là dessus
ce qui est sûr c'est que plus nous
retardons une reprise totale à cause de
la crise sanitaire qui viendraient la
freiner nous nous éloignons d'une
reprise à 1 6% de croissance en 2021
c'est évident est-ce que jamais
clairement sur ces chiffres étaient
auditionnés hier au sénat il parlait de
trois scénarii ils envisagent ils
n'envisageaient pas le scénario où la
croissance pourrait rester à 6%
vous savez peut se le dire entre c'est
ça se passe pas en ces termes là on fait
pas du paris chez des bookmakers
le troisième trimestre de l'année 2020 a
démontré une capacité de rebond bien
supérieur à ce qu'on imaginait
al'inverse + 18 % sur le troisième
trimestre de l'année 2020 parfois
l'économie française quand elle
redémarre ère démarre beaucoup plus fort
que ce qu'on imaginait donc on n'est
jamais à l'abri d'une bonne surprise en
terme de relance vous y croyez
oui si la crise sanitaire et maîtrisés
d'ici là c'est toujours la même chose il
faut pardon de le marteler mais quand je
dis que la crise sanitaire dicte la
crise économique
ce n'est pas un slogan c'est la pure
réalité de ce que nous vivons
actuellement tant que la crise sanitaire
n'est pas maîtrisée contrôler derrière
nous il est impossible pour quiconque de
faire des prévisions macroéconomiques de
croissance difficile et incertain mais
il faut il faut le faire cet ses
prévisions puisque il vous faut un
objectif de croissance aussi pour pour
bâtir un projet de loi de finances
rectificative et donc vous êtes obligés
de travailler il faut qu'il faut un
chiffre pour les lois de finances et
c'est de façon il en faut aussi pour la
commission mais ça c'est au gouvernement
de le décider ce que je veux juste vous
dire c'est que les chiffres sont
rapidement démentie par ce que la crise
les font mentir
rapidement il faut un peu d'humilité
dans cette crise on ferme
macroéconomique les choses changent a
rapidement d'accord donc il y aura du
rebond et de la croissance en 2021 c'est
à peu près un certain ça voudrait dire
sinon que vous aurez une année 2021 pire
que l'année 2001 c'est un scénario que
je me refuse d'imaginer en termes
économiques et sociales
en revanche effectivement peut-être que
le rebond sera moins puissant que son
projet de loi de finances rectificative
il arrive quand à l'assemblée nationale
ça ça va dépendre de la consommation des
crédits budgétaires pour faire face à
l'urgence que nous traversons
aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
il y a suffisamment de crédits
budgétaires qui ont été votés par le
parlement pour que le gouvernement ne
faisait penser à l'année dernière
so lu ment on avait eu du report de
l'année 2020 plus des nouveaux crédits
ont bien remis à total 20 milliards le
plus de nouveaux crédits ça voudrait
dire qu'on pourrait tenir jusqu'à l'été
ça dépendra de la décision de décision
qui crée ou non un nouveau freinage de
l'économie et qui nécessiteraient ou non
d'avoir des aides complémentaires et
auquel cas en fonction de la
consommation des crédits budgétaires
disponibles
il faudrait ou non faire un projet de
loi finances rectificative à mon sens à
mon sens s'il y avait des nouvelles
mesures restrictives
il serait bon que le gouvernement
présente au parlement une nouvelle
feuille de route donc à nouveau au
budget rectificatif
mais c'est au gouvernement évidemment
pour décider alors est passé au reste de
l'actualité parce qu'il est encore
beaucoup de sujets on va quand même
continuer à parler du coc vite puisque à
l'assemblée nationale hier la mission
d'information sur la crise sanitaire sur
locaux vides a pris fin malgré les
protestations de l'opposition damien
abad qui est le chef du groupe
d'opposition le chef dlr à l'assemblée
parle de naufrage démocratique
totalement surréaliste collet
répondez-vous que le rapport a été rendu
que c'est un mauvais débat politicien et
qu'on n'a vraiment pas besoin de ça et
je le dis en toute sympathie avec damien
abad qui est un bon président de groupe
et qui est un homme politique de talent
que je respecte beaucoup mais là
honnêtement on aurait pu s'en passer de
cette sortie la dame née à ban fait
exprès de laisser penser qu'il ya une
sorte de censure que la majorité musée
larrey de la capacité de gauche comme de
droite un le brouiller il faudrait un
moment la réponse était simple à votre
question c'est le rapport a été rendu
konami sont les travaux la crise n'est
pas terminée et la major dans la
majorité sénatoriale fait ce qu'elle
souhaite de ses missions le travail
selon le calendrier imparti de la
mission d'information de l'assemblée
nationale a été terminée tant qu'un
monnier que tout le monde y compris
l'opposition avait accepté d'accord si
demain il ya d'autres travaux qui se
crée de façon transparente izan pourquoi
pas mais de là à les dire qu'on a
arrêtée brutalement des travaux qui
avait un calendrier qui était prévu y
compris par les membres de l'opposition
comme tel c'est un peu fort de café
c'est assez malhonnête et surtout
surtout si les oppositions en ce moment
n'ont que ça à dire alors pour aller
attaquer le gouvernement et la majorité
c'est que vraiment les
contre-propositions de fonds sont les
messieurs st martin en valeur on va
poser la question différemment est-ce
que selon vous il est nécessaire à
l'assemblée nationale nous continuer à
avoir une mission d'information sur la
gestion de la crise de la crise
sanitaire
est-ce que c'est pas logique non mais
que va-t-on faire avec une mission
d'information de plus moi vous savez je
suis en bout s'est terminée il ya plus
il ya plus de dix heures de la mission
d'inspection de l'assemblée nationale ne
doit pas passer par ce biais là j'ai pas
dit ça je suis un défenseur du parlement
- le parlement contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et évalue les politiques
publiques donc en temps de crise que le
parlement fasse des travaux de suivi et
d'information de requête est tout à fait
naturel je rappelle que l'assemblée
nationale dès le début de la crise dès
le début de la crise sur proposition de
richard ferrand a monté une mission
d'information qui s'est poursuivie en
commission manquer ça me fait rire avec
toi même comme rapporteur général eric
ciotti
pas franchement de la majorité on peut
pas nous faire le procès d'avoir fermé
les portes de l'en quête au parlement
qu'elle phare la majorité du temps a mis
exactement en a mis exactement tous les
voies et moyens pour que le parlement
permette à la majorité à l'opposition de
faire son travail dans quête si ça doit
continuer dans le futur parce que il ya
des éléments intéressants aller chercher
ce sera fait j'ai aucun doute là dessus
tout c'est injuste fait en bonne
intelligence
ce que je dis encore une fois tu es que
la façon d'aller attaquer et d'aller
dire qu'une mission d'information se
termine alors que le calendrier était
prévu comme tel ça s'appelle de la
mauvaise foi et de la manipulation
on va parler des régionales jean michel
blanckaert qui a clairement fait
comprendre qu'il ne mènerait
la liste de la majorité présidentielle
en ile-de-france est ce que vous êtes
candidat pour la congère j'ai dit déjà
plusieurs reprises que le collectif que
nous avions monté autour de jean michel
blanquer comme chef de file
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois fonctionnait bien que
j'avais coordonner les groupes de
travail pour construire un projet commun
et que s'il fallait quelqu'un pour en
ramasser le drapeau comme on dit c'est à
dire poursuivre le travail de jean
michel comme chef de file je me rendais
disponible et je me proposais il ya
d'autres talents dans la majorité
probablement pour le faire et ce qui
vaut à moi de faire un casting
ce que je veux juste vous dire c'est que
tu vas bien falloir un candidat dans les
prochains jours ce que je veux dit de
vous dire c'est qu'il n'y ait que vous
ce qui m'importe moi c'est qu'il ya un
consensus rapide maintenant les
collectifs qui sont rapides à quel
horizon tour je crois val de quoi de
jour d'heure n'ont pas dehors quand même
mais peut-être effectivement de quelques
jours pour que nous puissions continuer
à avancer et surtout surtout que les
questions de personnes ce qui fait
normalement notre force ne viennent pas
bloquer un travail de fond qui marche
bien voilà c'est ma seule requête je
veux que ce que nous avons commencé au
niveau du travail pour les franciliens
parce que vraiment j'insiste c'est ça
qui compte pour les franciliens soient
poursuivies soit continuer la question
de l'incarnation
elle doit être réglée parce que ça fait
partie de la vie publique et de la vie
politique bien entendu on l'a réglera
entre nous entre majorité la république
en marche mais aussi avec les
partenaires parce que c'est important
que nous montrions rarement mais aussi
avec le modèle de progrès se soient
réunis pour partir dans sa compagne âgée
cette grande famille elle sera bien
réunis parce que évidemment il y avait
des interrogations sur le soutien ou non
du modem certains s'interrogent dans
certaines régions je parle pour l'ami à
nouveau de france mais la vôtre aussi
est concernée en ile-de-france ce qu'ils
sont bien derrière vous d'abord il
faudra que vous invitiez le modem
pour en équiper évidemment que nous en
parlons aucun doute mais aucun doute que
le modem en tant que partie prenante
importante de la majorité présidentielle
partent en campagne avec la république
en marche lors des élections régionales
je n'ai aucun doute là-dessus qu'après
il y ait éventuellement quelques
personnes et d'une majorité sortante qui
ne souhaite plus à obtenir au modem pour
repartir avec vela majeur avec lui se
contente après tout ce sont des choix
individuels
c'est le cas mais les mouches je n'en
sais rien mais les mouvements politiques
les mouvements politiques doivent être
unis effectivement ce sont les cadres et
ce sont aussi les militants et c'est une
dynamique de campagne qui doit commencer
rapidement je crois pour pouvoir
démontrer que la majorité présidentielle
lors des élection régionales non
seulement elle existe mais a fait des
propositions fortes 116 guérini qui
était sur ce plateau il ya quelques
semaines disait que la république en
marche et est disponible pour discuter
avec les présidents de région sortants
pour voir comment vous pourriez
travailler ensemble est-ce que vous
allez discuter avec valérie pécresse ou
est ce que vous dites non nous on ira y
aura pas il y aura pas de discussion au
premier tour serait moi ce que je vous
dis c'est que nous partons compagne
majorité présidentielle valérie pécresse
je croise il sauf si j'ai raté un
épisode n'est pas membre de la majorité
président ni devons faire une campagne
qui nous est propre avec nos valeurs nos
idées nous avons des choses différentes
a proposé ne faut pas insulter l'avenir
il faut savoir ce qu'on a proposé aux
franciliens quand on part en campagne en
ile de france
ni plus pardon ni plus ni moins l'avenir
nous le verrons bien nous verrons bien
et insulté la ville ça veut dire que
vous pourriez discuté dans l'entre-deux
tours je veux dire que nous ne partons
pas du principe que s'adressait à des
électeurs en disant avec qui on va
gouverner est une bonne manière de faire
nous nous partons en campagne pour dire
pour qui on va gouverner pour qui on
veut gouverner et ça c'est extrêmement
important
c'est aux électeurs de décider au
premier tour ce qu'il considère comme le
plus propice à leurs attentes
d'accord et après évidemment ça sert à
ça d'avoir deux tours après
effectivement peut y avoir des accords
il peut ne pas y en avoir et ça se
poursuit jusqu'à l'issue du second tour
ce n'est certainement pas aujourd'hui au
28 janvier 2021
à nous d'en décider ni à qui que ce soit
il faut que les campagnes se déroule
sereinement avec des projets
positif avec des idées qu'ils soient
claires moi j'aimerais savoir par
exemple ce que les autres candidats on
va proposer pour réduire les fractures
d'inégalités qui ont continué à se
creuser en ile-de-france pendant toute
ces dernières années nous avons des
idées nous allons les proposer nous
pourrions le décliner sur plusieurs
thèmes et la démocratie pardon mais et
la démocratie est aussi simple que ça
parfois vous avez différents
représentants politiques qui propose
différentes idées il peut y avoir après
les idées qui convergent
il peut ne pas y en avoir et c'est aux
électeurs de décider cette simplicité
cette pureté démocratique je tiens la
conserver pour les élections régionales
d'île de france c'est à dire proposer
des idées rien des idées rien des
solutions aux franciliens et ce seront
franciliens d'en décider
et oui est ce qu on pourrait avoir aussi
une appréciation
c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de
valérie pécresse mais qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la candidature de d'audrey
pulvar mais elle est toute légitime la
candidature d'audrey pulvar de la même
manière que celle de monsieur bayou que
celle de madame autant que celle
peut-être de monsieur bardella comme
j'entends le serait également rêver à
vendre la division à gauche quand même
non rien ne m'arrange je veux qu'on
travaille avec des idées qui nous
ressemble vous avez des candidats qui
sont des personnalités qui ont du talent
et qui ont aussi des idées mais elles
sont différentes ses idées est-ce qu'on
peut revenir à l'essence de ce qui fait
la noblesse de la politique de ce pour
quoi on s'engage c'est à dire proposer
des choses dans lesquelles on croit et
c'est propice et sont franciliens
décider quand pardon ses propositions et
arriveront quand nous sommes encore une
fois au 28 janvier
aucun candidat n'a présenté encore de
programme et c'est normal
j'imaginais déjà des propositions med ce
qui est sûr c'est que nous travaillons
et nous avons beaucoup d'idées
donc tant mieux merci beaucoup de nous
voir regarder une de la voix du nord
c'est flunch flunch appel à l'aide
c'était là une grosse inquiétude autour
du gros fun champ du feu lire dans la
voix du nord merci beaucoup
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics
vous vous présent
[Musique]